non mesdames messieurs bonjour le
conseil
des ministres s'est tenu ce matin et le
président de la république a insisté
dans son propos liminaire sur les deux
chantiers que continueront de mener de
front et c'est encore le cas évidemment
cette semaine elle évidemment nous rend
très intense placée sous le signe de la
réponse face à l'épidémie de la relance
de l'emploi la première préoccupation
bien sûr notre première préoccupation
reste d'alix contre l'équipe de kobe 19
face à l'évolution l'épidémie un conseil
de défense consacré à la question des
recettes vous savez vendredi dernier il
a permis les décisions fortes prises en
concertation avec les territoires par le
représentant de l'état dans ces
territoires
évidemment à bordeaux à marseille ils
ont loué le suivant notre stratégie de
réponse locale et adaptée de nouvelles
décisions pourraient être prises après
concertation le ministre des solidarités
de la santé aux différents vous en fera
pas demain lors de son point presse le
président de la république a demandé que
cette conférence de presse sera
l'occasion d'abord une transparence
absolue sur la réalité de la reprise
épidémique dans notre pays sur les
chiffres sur la circulation du virus et
sur les projections que nous pouvons
avoir aujourd'hui à moyen et à long
terme
il a demandé par ailleurs que cette
conférence de presse se tiendra demain
après-midi soit l'occasion d'une
présentation claire mais la logique de
la stratégie de notre pays pour mener le
combat face à sète
le deuxième sujet je vais viser
a lens commencé celui de la relance est
très marquée notamment par les mesures
industrielles comprenons dans le cadre
du plan de relance je rappelle la
philosophie de ce qui est de saisir
cette crise comme une opportunité pour
relancer notre pays pour le projeter
dans l'avenir en investissant sur des
secteurs majeurs et qui seront
essentiels pour que notre pays puisse
tenir son rang dans la compétition la
mondiale aidant développement de notre
économie
ensuite le conseil des ministres a été
l'occasion pour la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation de revenir sur la
rentrée universitaire cette français se
déroule évidemment dans un contexte
particulier à la fois du fait de la
crise sanitaire et du non exceptionnel
des étudiants souhaitant poursuivre des
études supérieures dans ce contexte
réussir la rentrée universitaire était
un défi mais un défi que nous devions
relever car il en va de la continuité
des études de la qualité de notre offre
de formations et de la capacité enfin
évidemment demain pour les étudiantes et
les étudiants à trouver un emploi sur le
plan sanitaire des consignes claires et
strictes ont été édictées le corps du
masque obligatoire le respect existants
des différenciations physique à chaque
fois que cela est possible notamment en
occupant en plastron en amphi qu'un
fauteuil sur deux ces mesures sont
nécessaires et devront être appliquées
que la plus grande vigilance la plus
grande précaution à la fois la maîtrise
de l'épidémie et l'avenir de nos
étudiants dans leurs études en étant je
veux dire aussi que nous sommes prêts à
toutes les évolutions sanitaires à ses
messages qu'a rappelé la ministre
chaque établissement a établi un plan de
continuité pédagogique qui permettra
sans cesse d'ajuster les équilibres
entre un renseignement à distance ou en
présentiel en fonction de la situation
c'était aussi l'occasion de rappeler la
mise en oeuvre du plan jeunes je veux
permettre de faire très rapidement
devant bon puisque la question
l'information et la communication sur
les mesures que nous prenons est
essentielle à la fois pour les acteurs
économiques et pour les jeunes qui se
lancent sur le marché du travail je
rappelle que la philosophie de ce plan
c'est un jeune une solution proposée
avec un accompagnement sur mesure et
notamment fait par les missions locales
pour les choses qui sont aujourd'hui
sans solution et les éloigner des
perspectives que nous leur devons je
veux rappeler des mesures qui ont été
prises pour augmenter le nombre de
missions de service civique pour les
jeunes qui souhaiteraient s'engager je
veux rappeler les mesures qui ont été
prises pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
un coût zéro pour les entreprises dans
le recrutement d'un apprenti pour cette
première année c'est très important de
le rappeler la ministre du travail a eu
l'occasion de rappeler les chiffres
encourageants à ce stade que nous
observons s'agissant de l'apprentissage
rappelle que la hausse historique d
inscrire l'apprentissage avaient été
constatés l'an dernier
et évidemment notre objectif est de
maintenir cette dynamique et puis des
mesures en direction des entreprises qui
recrutent des jeunes je rappelle le
crime de 4000 euros pour les entreprises
qui recruteront un jeune j'en profite
pour rappeler aussi que cette prime est
ouverte pour les entreprises pour
recrutement une personne en situation de
handicap quel que soit son âge
deuxième point abordé lors de nos
échanges un bilan de la saison
touristique qui a été fait par les
monstres de l'europe des affaires
étrangères le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance et le
secrétaire d'état chargé du le tourisme
c'est un point très important compte
tenu de l'attractivité de la france et
du nombre d'emplois dans ce secteur
touristique en particulier l'été l'an
dernier nous avions a connu là aussi une
hausse exceptionnelle de l'affairé
touristique en france et nous nous
attendions regarde la situation
évidemment c'est une situation
catastrophique
le bilan est moins sombre que nous
l'avons train d'abord parce que nous
observons nous avons mieux connu qu'un
certain nombre de nos voisins notamment
sur le taux de remplissage des hôtels il
était de 50% en france l'habilité de
l'ordre de 30% chez un certain nombre de
voisins ce qui est un signe encourageant
ensuite parce que les français ont
massivement choisi un tourisme bleu
blanc rouge
un tourisme en france qui a eu lieu cet
été toutefois on observe évidemment de
grandes disparités selon les clients
et selon les territoires les
destinations du littoral et de la
campagne ont été privilégiés par les
touristes saison a été par contre
difficile dans un certain nombre de
territoires à paris notamment où la
moitié des hôtels était ouvert et où le
taux d'occupation observée a été
particulièrement faible mais aussi en
corse mais aussi dans les territoires
ultramarins dans un certain nombre
d'autres parfois de métropole notons
également une diminution importante de
la consommation touristique et donc tout
cela vous appelle évidemment à agir ce
que nous avons fait depuis le début et
je veux rappeler que le secteur
touristique a pu bénéficier d'un soutien
massif de la part de l'état plan
d'urgence pour le tourisme à hauteur de
18 milliards d'euros avait été lancée en
mai dernier 13 milliards d'euros ont
déjà été mobilisés notamment pour le
prêt garanti par l'état pour le fonds de
solidarité au secteur de l'hôtellerie et
de la restauration il ya des secteurs en
difficulté c'était l'objet de nos
échanges notamment c'est par des
opérateurs de voyages qui organise
notamment des voyages scolaires le
secteur de l'événementiel
le président de la république a demandé
de continuer à suivre ses peurs
d'affiner ma réponse
prendre de nouvelles initiatives pour
accompagner très fortement ses peurs et
notamment les plus petites structures
qui souffrent particulièrement
il a demandé aussi qu'une attention
particulière et des mesures
particulières soit prévu pour un certain
nombre de territoires que j'évoquais à
l'instant notamment les outre-mer
notamment la corse en ayant un regard et
une attention à des secteurs qui ne sont
pas considérés immédiatement comme des
secteurs touristiques mais qui dépendent
beaucoup du tourisme
je pense notamment au secteur
agroalimentaire en corse qui suivit nos
difficultés du fait de la baisse de
fréquentation touristique depuis enfin
s'agissant de la bible lourd beaucoup
devenir un tourisme évidemment très
particulier et une situation est devenue
très particulière avec une attention
doit être apporté des mesures s'agissant
notamment de la question des saisonniers
n'aurait cependant que très attentif à
la situation et le premier ministre
réunira un nouveau comité
interministériel du tourisme dans le
courant du mois d'octobre qui sera
l'occasion à la fois de faire rapport
écrit d'avancé sur les différents
chantiers que j'ai évoqués mais aussi
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux des
initiatives pour être prise avant ce
conseil des ministres a aussi été
l'occasion d'examiner si texte si texte
dont beaucoup ont des conséquences très
concrètes pour ou un citoyen je vais
revenir rapidement sur ses textes ses
jours pour répondre à des questions et
éventuellement le premier d'entre eux
c'est le projet de loi qui courage le
régime transitoire qui a été instituée à
la sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
vous en souvenez à la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
le 9 juillet dernier la france est
entrée dans une période transitoire qui
permet de prendre vite des décisions
adaptées pour combattre l'épidémie
ce régime transitoire devait en refrain
le 30 octobre prochain le 30 octobre
prochain
compte tenu de la situation sanitaire
que vous connaissez il est nécessaire
d'anticiper de nous donner tous les
outils pour continuer à battre les vides
contre le virus et donc prolonger la
période transitoire sera prolongé
jusqu'au 1er avril 2021
quand je dois prévoir un certain nombre
de mesures en ce sens le deuxième texte
présenté est un sujet quotidien pour
nous français il s'agit des fourrières
automobile le projet de loi ratifiant
l'ordonnancé que la si do fourrière
automobile a été présenté il va
permettre la création d'un système
d'information national des fourrières
permettant l'enregistrement la gestion
et le suivi des véhicules mises en
fourrière voir sa voiture enlevé placé
en fourrière n'est jamais une récompense
ni une partie de plaisir mais il n'est
pas normal d'être confrontés à des
obstacles administratifs pénible et
multiples aussi grâce à ce système les
démarches des français seront plus
faciles projet de loi va également
modifier la procédure d'avant d'abandon
d'un véhicule en fourrière désormais il
n'y aura plus besoin d'un expert en
automobile un classement automatisé
permettra de réunir toutes les
informations sur le véhicule concerné et
donc de décider de l'avenir des
véhicules abandonnés de façon bien plus
facile et efficace
le troisième texte étudié est une
ordonnance relative à l'harmonisation et
à la simplification des polices des
immeubles locaux et installations
très concrètement il s'agit de renforcer
notre combat et notre lutte contre
l'habitat indigne en simplifiant
considérablement notre droit pour vous
donner une idée aujourd'hui pour
examiner la sécurité et la salubrité
d'un immeuble une dizaine de procédures
existent et sont disséminés dans
plusieurs codes législatif avec ce test
ce texte nous voulons donc gagner en
efficacité puisqu'il n'y aura plus
qu'une seule et unique police
administrative compétente police
administrative spéciale de la sécurité
la salubrité des immeubles notre
objectif est clair c'est permettre aux
habitants d'immeubles insalubres d'aller
plus vite dans leurs démarches et d'être
entendue plus rapidement dans la droite
ligne de notre volonté d'impliquer plus
encore les territoires ce texte va par
ailleurs renforcer les pouvoirs des
maires et des présidents de pci
l'idée ce texte et pouvoir donner des
moyens d'action rapide pour des élus qui
sont directement en contact des
habitants
le quatrième texte que nous avons
examinés et une ordonnance portant
création au sein du code de commerce
une division spécifique aux sociétés
dont les titres sont admis aux
négociations sur un marché réglementé ou
sur un système multilatéral de
négociation alors derrière c'est au nom
de quoi parle-t-on des entreprises
cotées en bourse des entreprises qui
sont donc soumises à des règles
particulières et un suivi très strict
cependant jusqu'à présent les
dispositions qu'il est concerné n'était
pas regrouper et se trouvait ça ira dans
le code de commerce dans le code
monétaire et financier nous avons nous
décidé de regrouper toutes les
dispositions d'un chapitre unique au
sein du code de commerce est une mesure
cohérente avec notre volonté de
continuer à simplifier la vie des
français simplifier la vie des
entreprises simplifier le droit et par
là même service et les recherches et la
vie des entreprises concernées le
cinquième texte que nous avons examiné
un décret qui modifie le code de la
légion d'honneur la médaille militaire
et de l'ordre national du mérite
une fois de plus c'est dans un souci de
simplification de ce projet a été pensé
simplification administrative d'abord en
alignant la date d'achèvement du mandat
de leurs membres mais aussi en
simplifiant le fonctionnement et
d'adaptation à la situation sanitaire
puisqu'il va notamment permettre au
conseil de l'ordre de la légion
d'honneur conseil de l'ordre national du
mérite de délibérer sur leur choix par
visioconférence enfin le dernier texte
que nous avons examiné un décret
relatifs à la sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
à mayotte et en guyane l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire dans ces territoires
permet de mettre fin dès aujourd'hui à
l'état d'urgence et à mayotte et à
l'habillage de rentrer dans le régime
transitoire que j'évoquais à l'instant
s'agissant du premier texte que je vous
ai présenté c'est à dire le même régime
qui s'applique pour le reste du pays
voilà mesdames et messieurs ce que je
pouvais vous dire de ce conseil des
ministres égyptien maintenant à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
oui
bonjour marie sont très pur à tous les
français concernant l'annoncent pour
sociale là à bridgestone à béthune la
fermeture de cette usine près de 800
emplois supprimés la direction met en
avant des problèmes de concurrence de
coûts quelle est la réponse aujourd'hui
face à ces constats sur donc leur celui
là est peut-être d'autres qui s'annonce
dans les pressings
nous avons appris comme vous l'annoncé
de ce plan social chez les stones la
fermeture de l'usiné de béthune se sont
à plusieurs centaines d'emplois qui sont
menacés c'est un chat mais c'est aussi
une décision brutale sur la forme
incompréhensible sur le son est une
trahison de la confiance que l'état et
la région ou de france où placer en
bridgestone
on est dans l'usiné depuis des années
mais gestion doit aujourd'hui assumer
ses responsabilités plutôt que de
chercher des prétextes
c'est l'entreprise qui a sous investi
dans le site de béthune profit d'autres
sites c'est cette entreprise qui a été
incapable d'instaurer les conditions
d'un dialogue social
sans ces sept entreprises enfin qui n'a
fait aucune proposition en l'état et la
région de france ont présenté des
mesures de soutien dans le cadre du plan
de relance
aujourd'hui notre priorité notre seule
priorité c'est la sauvegarde de l'emploi
et l'accompagnement des salariés nous
allons donc réunir dans les prochains
jours les représentants du personnel et
les élus du territoire nous allons
exiger de bridgestone de faire son
travail de mener une étude approfondie
des scénarios alternatifs de fermeture
de l'usiné compte tenu des moyens qui
sont mis en place dans le plan de
relance nous agirons avec la région une
france avec laquelle nous sommes
totalement en ligne
nous agirons avec la plus grande
résolution et je répondais en cela la
deuxième question qui est d'abord dans
le cadre du plan de relance nous avons
mis en place des mesures massives
précisément pour continuer à protéger
l'emploi et continue à protéger
l'activité économique pour notre pays
en cohérence avec ce que nous avons fait
depuis le début de cette crise avec le
rappel des mesures qui ont été mises en
place
chômage partiel prêts garantis par les
parcs ont solidarité l'exonération de
charges qui vise à protéger l'emploi et
d'en prendre là nous allons plus loin
encore avec la diminution des impôts de
production qui rentre en vigueur l'an
prochain mais dès à présent avec un
bouclier anti chômage qui permet pour
les entreprises d'avoir recours à ce
dispositif pour maintenir dans l'emploi
des salariés en bien même
j'aurai avec un soutien financier de
l'état pour l'accompagnement nécessaire
évidemment c'est notre grande priorité
je le disais au début de mon
intervention à la question industrielle
le coeur de travaux est au coeur de
l'actualité du gouvernement cette
semaine pour vous le maire sera
meilleure en déplacement demain sur le
sujet de soutien aux entreprises aux
salariés je l'accompagnerai à cette
occasion et vous que c'est évidemment
cadre là que nous continuons à avancer
je voulais
et alors que la question sur le thème
sur les causes ide et certains journaux
on est évoqué la possibilité que ça
donnait la priorité pour passer les
tests à ceux qui téléchargent aurait la
tâche historique fait savoir s'il y en
avait été question est pour vous
l'allemagne a édité un stratégie en vue
d'un vaccin en indiquant que le vaccin
ne serait pas obligatoire mais qu'elle
comptait sur lui pour arriver à limiter
unité collective à l'ami de nouveaux
clients est ce que nous avons arrêté une
stratégie en cas d'un nombre d'accents
plutôt que juste à dire 10 dans les
clubs russes qui n'ont pas forcément des
regrets pour revient sur les dernières
questions sur ce que mitigé sur eux une
est-ce que ne-yo rappeler s'il ya des
contreparties
les entreprises qui reçoivent des aides
à l'oeuvre au maintien de l'emploi
remercié alors sur la première question
je n'ai pas entendu parler de cette
information et pour dire les choses
clairement ce matin en conseil des
ministres il ya eu une communication sur
la situation sanitaire du gouffre de la
santé mais l'essentiel des discussions
se sont tenues
dans le cadre du conseil de défense
consacré aux visites je rappelle que le
ministre aura l'occasion de s'exprimer
demain qu'il fait précisément la
conférence de presse pour répondre à
toutes vos questions sur ces sujets là
et que je ne vais donc pas faire la
conférence de presse avant la conférence
de presse mais qu'il aura l'occasion de
revenir notamment sur les questions que
vous évoquez s'agissant de l'application
peut-être qu vide et s'agissant de la
stratégie de notre pays à la fois pour
vivre avec le virus puisque aujourd'hui
c'est ce que nous devons faire et puis
sur les sujets à venir et notamment
celui du du vaccin sur la deuxième
question qui est la vôtre je vous
rappeler que la première contrepartie de
l'investissement de l'état gouvernement
pour les entreprises dans le cadre du
plan de relance c'est l'emploi de
contenus a investi des manières
financier montraient une prime pour les
entreprises qui recrutent des jeunes des
travailleurs en situation de handicap
évidemment la contrepartie pour toucher
la prime c'est de recruter un jeune qui
vont travailler en situation de handicap
quand on met en place des diminutions
d'impôts de production sadi de que de
l'activité soit ancrée relocaliser en
france c'est notre rang d'objectif la
france est aujourd'hui l'un des pays qui
a les notes de production est plus élevé
ce qui n'encourage pas la localisation
d'activités notamment industriels sur
une fois territoire et donc c'est la
première des contreparties c'est
évidemment celle là il s'agissant des
éleveurs qui ont pu être aidée de
manière spécifique depuis le début de
cette crise il ya là aussi un dialogue
je terminerai en citant l'exemple que je
suis tout à l'heure sur ce qu'on appelle
bouclier anti chômage c'est l'état qui
apporte à des entreprises des moyens
financiers sachant que ces entreprises
en contrepartie s'engagent à ne pas
licencier salariés concernés
mais à réduire leur temps de travail ce
qui permet par ailleurs de se former
pour éventuellement aller vers d'autres
professions contrepartie d'un soutien
financier de l'état mais bonjour mathieu
couach bfmtv une question sur les
réflexions de liberté qui a la main
aujourd'hui dans la prise de cette
décision et ce sont des préfets et soul
est ce que ces gouvernements et est ce
que parfois les uns et les autres n'ont
pas tendance à se renvoyer la balle
faute de règles très claires sur ces
questions alors sur ce qu'on changerait
le même chapeau que la réponse à votre
concert précédemment étant donné qu'il
ya la plus grande différence demain je
n'étais pas moins représentées faire la
conférence parce qu'il doit faire mais
nous avons assumé une stratégie nous
continuons à sur une stratégie qui est
celle de la territorialisation ça a été
un des grands enseignements du premier
pic de l'épidémie décision nationale qui
a été de confiner l'ensemble du pays qui
était nécessaire dans le cadre du des
musulmans nous avons assumé de parier
bien sûr le couple maires préfets et aux
fonds d'adapter le cadre national la
stratégie nationale qui est la nôtre aux
circonstances le cas depuis ce que
l'épidémie ne circule pas forcément
l'année dernière selon les territoires
que les foyers d'infection ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes selon les
territoires et que ça nécessite
l'ajuster au niveau local donc il ya un
cadre d'une stratégie est celle de
l'état et que olivier ferrand rappellera
décidera demain et répondre à toutes les
questions qui sont les vôtres sur ce
sujet là il ya ensuite une adaptation
locale par l'état aussi puisque le
préfet m
et le représentant de l'état dans les
territoires pour penser le préfet qui
prend des mesures c'est évidemment des
tac transfusion et le fait en
concertation avec les élus locaux
vous savez parfois on entend certains
qui demandent la première vague vaudrait
également que les décisions soit reprise
depuis par et parfois méconnaissance de
la réalité de certains territoires qui
aujourd'hui considèrent qu'ils vont se
réunir pour prendre des mesures après
concertation avec les élus locaux pour
s'adapter à la situation de tentes
nous continuons à arie ce volet là
analyse boom de globo news le
gouvernement s'est toujours pas exprimée
sur la lettre de monsieur le drian à
bernard arnault de lvmh la semaine
dernière me disait que le ministre des
affaires étrangères s'exprimerait sur le
sujet il ne l'a pas fait quand est ce
que monsieur le lien entre nous en dire
plus sur cette lettre est ce que vous
même vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
il a décidé effectivement de l'envoyer
s'il a été sollicité par le super g pas
d'information supplémentaire a donné par
rapport à ce que j'ai dit la semaine
dernière le gouvernement s'était pas
exprimé j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer de
la semaine dernière
je crois que mon collègue bruno le maire
a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer cette
semaine
en réponse à une question à vous nos
nouveaux concerts sur une matinale t es
pas même qu'il ya eu une dépêche sur ce
sujet là parce que c'est comme ça que
j'en ai pris connaissance et privés sur
ce sujet en rappelant que j'aurais
devait y en avait pris la mesure qui
jugeait la plus efficace pour défendre
les intérêts de la france dans son rôle
de mimi les affaires étrangères dans un
contexte de tensions commerciales
notamment avec les états unis et sur ce
plan j'ai pas davantage de choses à vous
dire je crois que le message a été passé
à la fois par mois la semaine dernière
par mon collègue inconditionnels ont pas
de prise de parole de celle d'avant que
je n'ai pas d'informations sur l'agenda
de w9 mais il est régulièrement en
déplacement au contact notamment des
journalistes tout pour répondre à vos
questions sur les plateaux et donc vous
pas qu'il aura l'occasion de le faire en
répondant à une question rapidement
bonjour j marie lecomte france info je
me permets de revenir sur la question de
ma consoeur de la lfp concernant
l'application stop cogite dans la mesure
où c'est ce matin que le conseil de
défense et aujourd'hui que un certain
nombre
d'acteurs et de politiques s'inquiètent
du projet les gouvernements est ce que
est ce que déjà vous pouvez me dire si
au moins une grande campagne de
communication qui n'a toujours pas eu
lieu sur sur 7 sur cette application est
envisagée dans les prochains jours et
effectivement quelle est la corrélation
nous dire ou démentir le fait que
télécharger cette application donnerait
un accès prioritaire aux tests merci
beaucoup
alors j'ai leur raison d'être car dans
ma réponse à votre salon mais cabaye
examen là suffisamment donc lorsque ça
veut dire que le gouvernement mais on
est en mai en attente la réponse à ces
questions c'est ce que j'ai dit au
départ dès le jeu suivant les conseils
de ministres ou les conseils de défense
auquel j'ai participé je n'ai pas
entendu parler de cet antique été
avancée par votre console je veux pas
être plus clair que ça je n'ai pas
entendu parler de ce sujet là et pour
moi aujourd'hui ça n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour puisque je n'ai pas entendu
parler dans les nombreuses réunions
consacrées à la colline 19 auquel j'ai
participé la deuxième chose que je vis
c'est que nous croyons à ce prix pour
pas non à son utilité puisque c'est
l'objectif de
pouvoirs publics dans le cadre de cette
épidémie comme c'est le cas dans
l'ensemble et et notamment chez nos
voisins s'est testé et c'est
d'identifier des cars contact pour leur
permettre de se mettre à l'abri et donc
protégé de patrick que l'application est
un outil utile pour une par une
maintenant ça suscite sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas trouvé son
public mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut renoncer au contraire qu'est ce que
je dis c'est que l'iran fera de manière
beaucoup plus longue
nourrie que moi d'abord vous dire
pourquoi est ce que nous développerons
sa fille
comment est ce que l enseignement nous
allons adapter la stratégie pour le
développer et les recommandations que
nous faisons pour renforcer son usage
depuis la communication vous avez autour
de cette équipe c'était plus tard
l'hiver pour la tène question sur
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle notamment pour le
scrutin législatif est une promesse de
campagne de wade mâcon hier face aux
députés jean castex lui a dit que les
français avaient vraiment d'autres
préoccupations en ce moment est ce qu'il
faut comprendre que ce projet de réforme
et est enterré ou est-ce que la promesse
d' emmanuel macron sera bien tenue avant
la fin de son quinquennat
vous avez raison de rappeler que les
manuels matin a présenté dans son
programme devant les français moi même
en tant que candidat aux élections
législatives à l'époque j'étais campagne
sur un programme législatif qui prévoit
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle
pourquoi pour permettre une pluralité
politique plus importante soit
d'exprimer à l'assemblée nationale et
que les différentes sensibilités
politiques qui traversent notre pays
soit plus représenté à l'assemblée
nationale vous aura pas échappé ensuite
que nous avons reporté ce projet dans le
cadre d'une réforme institutionnelle
plus vaste que nous avons présenté et
défendu lé au parlement en 2018 qui a
été bloqué par la majorité sénatoriale à
part les oppositions à la son image
on était bloqué toute avancée
institutionnelle et douches cette une
grande représentation politique à
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi le fond
mesures comme par exemple le non cumul
des mandats dans le temps ou la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
qui sont des engagements du président
d'arles et comme tout engagement le
président de la république
évidemment que notre objectif est de les
tenir il faut poursuivre cet objectif
avec un principe de réalité qui est
d'abord celui qu'il ya les messages et
les conservatismes politique au
parlement qui nous ont empêché jusqu'à
maintenant à d'avancé sur ces sujets là
ensuite qu'il est aujourd'hui une
réalité dans notre pays qui est
la circulation du virus donc notre
première grande priorité la lutte contre
l'épidémie
aussi la relance nécessaire de notre
économie si je devais résumer en une
phrase le cc finances qu'il appréciait
c'est un sujet qui est toujours sur la
table dont qui n'est pas au taquet pour
nous puisque nous avons ces priorités
qui pour le coup ça fait référence au
début de votre question et des propos
rapportés pour le coup je crois aussi
mobiliser bien davantage là les français
bonjour j'ai un niveau d'eau pour pour
europe 1 est ce que l'état avait
suffisamment de moyens dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie quand on voit qu'il
faut qu'il ya des longues files
d'attentes devant les laboratoires qu'il
faut parfois une semaine voire dix jours
pour avoir des résultats est ce que l'on
n'est pas finalement dans un manque de
moyens dans un manque d'anticipation qui
est préjudiciable à la lutte contre
entre le virus et petite question est ce
que vous même vous avez installé
l'habitation stocks revient alors sur la
première question
d'abord ce faire cinq questions qui
seront abordées donnant mais je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse parler dans la salle de
moyens la france est aujourd'hui l'un
des pays en a qui testent le plus
rapporté à son nombre d'habitants
contestent de plus qu'en allemagne
peut-être un certain nombre de pays d'oc
je vous réponds sur la question des
moyens après il ya des enjeux
d'organisation et c'est tout l'objet de
la présentation qui sera fait demain par
des blancs s'agissant notamment de la
question des tests et des enjeux de
l'organisation et de stratégie autour
des tests qui doivent nous permettre
d'être plus efficace lille allait
rappeler aujourd'hui il ya des délais
qui ne sont pas acceptables notamment
dans un certain nombre de territoires de
concentration faute
nous devons pour se faire tester il ya
des délais à la fois pour se faire
tester et des mails et revoir son
résultat sont inacceptables tout l'objet
de la stratégie qui sera présenté demain
par une télé en vous répondre
à l'opposé peut-être la question
autrement est ce que le président la
république a demandé plus d'efficacité
réelle des institutions à tous les
niveaux c'est à dire aussi bien des
laboratoires de quartier que l'était la
grèce et nous confirment que le
président la république au conseil de
défense la semaine dernière à vendredi a
demandé nous soyons plus efficacement la
stratégie pour des tests et c'est
l'objet de ce qui sera annoncé par
olivier v rendement que d'annoncer une
stratégie organisation qui permette de
répondre aux difficultés que nous
constatons aujourd'hui est que le
conseil constate nous avons tous le
livre entendu l'argument est aussi
comédien carl de la vente dans les
hauts-de-seine ou au secours des
messages de français qui veulent se
faire tester qui veulent que leurs
enfants se fassent tester parce qu'il
est impératif qu'ils sont confrontés à
des bureaux c'est bien attaque avec moi
et effectivement le président la
république a demandé que nous soyons
plus efficaces sur ce sujet là ils
verront alors l'occasion de dire comment
dès demain et votre avis et la peep
d'insurgés télécharger l'application en
fait l'idée j'appelle à chacune et
chacun à le faire
j'ai complété ce que vous disiez sur la
stratégie territorialisée de lutte
contre le coc vide parce que cela
signifie que demain nos jours qui
viennent il n'est plus question de
mesure qu'il conserverait toute la
population par exemple des façons leur
antre région des mesures inter
territoire je rappelle le fils au début
de cette crise que nous avons retenu
pour moi un enseignement qui est celui
de ne rien exclure par principe pour
l'avenir en général quand nous avons
collectivement ou individuellement
exclut les pistes pour l'avenir assez
vite on a été volatile par les faits
puisque c'est interdit
cotillons découvrira-t-il circulation
qui est propre qui est parfois
inattendues et donc évidemment s'adapte
à la situation il continuera à aller
mais je redis ce qui a été dit nous
avons des mesures nationales notamment
s'agissant de la prévention et des
gestes barrières sont très fortement
recommandée nous avons des mesures
nationales s'agissant notamment du port
du mat qui est systématisé dans les deux
clous recevant du public et dans les
entreprises dans les établissements
scolaires russie puis nous avons des
mesures locales
dès lors que certains territoires pour
constater que l'application de ces
mesures de prévention ne permet pas
d'endiguer la progression importante du
virus il y à des mesures locales de
restrictions qui sont prises par le
représentant de l'état dans ce
territoire en lien avec les
collectivités locales
je change complètement le sujet j'ai su
revenir sur les propos qui m'ont fait
beaucoup parler du président de la
république lundi soir sur la 5g
il a confirmé que la france prendrait ce
tournant là il ya un moratoire qui est
demandée par des élus de gauche
un moratoire demandé aussi par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat ce
n'a pas été un joker présenté par le
président et à accepter finalement ce
ces propositions et qui deux se disent
aujourd'hui trahis amer qu'est-ce que
président leur répond qu'est ce que leur
gouvernement le gouvernement leur répond
aujourd'hui à ces noms de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat d'abord sur ce
sujet là il faut entendre les questions
les buttes parfois les inquiétudes qui
sont l'ennemi par les français par des
associations par des élus et puis on va
répondre il faut que chacun accepte à la
fois d'entendre la réponse est de
regarder les faits qui sont présentés
sur la question de la convention
citoyenne est effectivement moratoire
qui a demandé dans la tente d'avoir des
informations et des recherches plus
importantes sur notamment la question du
risque sanitaire que je crois je n'ai
pas le texte sous les yeux de la
convention citoyens ou des échanges qui
ont lieu sur les bassins jugé qu'il
était aussi dit que c'était une
opportunité pour notre pays notamment
dans l'économique et en termes de
progrès dans la vie quotidienne des
français s'agissant de l'accès à la
piscine s'agissant de des économies
d'eau et d'énergie sur notre territoire
tout ça ce sont des progrès permis par
la sage et il se trouve que a été remis
les publié hier un rapport des ventes 16
qui fait la synthèse des rapports qui
ont été remis et la documentation
scientifique nourrit amoureuse qui a été
rogné sur ce sujet de la 5g tous
largement la question des ongles dans
notre pays et qui permettent de donner
des garanties pour avancer ensuite il ya
d'autres questionnements que celui
sanitaires notamment celui de sobriété
énergétique et de l'environnement et sur
ce point
d'autres rapports de l'inter venir je
crois au moins deux grandes évidemment
ils permettront d'adapter la mise en
place de la singer qui intervient
certain nombre ont été peu à peu sur ce
volet là il faut être assez clair il ya
des questions qui se posent il faut y
répondre
faux lui répond dans la carte et c'est
ce qu'on fait depuis le début il faut
pas perdre de vue non plus que c'est un
progrès immense pour les français de
pouvoir bénéficier à l'avenir de la
scène j'ai d'ailleurs quand on me pose
la question du moratoire elle regarde
vous pourrez mettre considéré comme
moratoire déjà eu lieu pendant son
enfance quand vous regardez la carte
européenne des pays qui l'ont installé
et développé la 5g vous voyez un îlot
qui est la france au milieu deux pays
qui se sont occupé je crois que c'est
tout ce pays européens qui commercialise
déjà la saint jean donc la question qui
est posée aujourd'hui je veux savoir
s'il veut que la france refuse de compte
ce virage là qui ont comme cela
permettra des progrès très concrètes
pour les français en terme médical en
terme
agroalimentaire en termes
environnemental ou est ce qu'on
considère qu' il faut ensuite c'est quoi
c'est notre logique de considérer qu'il
ya un chemin pour que le projet soit
fait au service de l'homme et l'égalité
dit les français c'est la logique du
plan de relance
vous avez entièrement de relance qui est
consacré aux progrès techniques
technologiques à l'activité économique
vous avez un tiers du carburant ce qui
est consacrée à la protection de notre
environnement et c'est sa note à
d'autres questions là je remercie
nouveau puis je le dis la semaine
prochaine nous avons besoin c'est très
nouveau pour la conférence de face de
mon collègue qui permettra répond à
toutes les questions que vous posez
merci beaucoup
vous voulez on va faire
qui appartenait